las barreras de hormigón indican que el
enemigo no está lejos
decenas de trincheras se han cavado para
preparar una eventual invasión de las
tropas ubicadas del lado bielorruso y el
antes activo paso fronterizo ha quedado
prácticamente bloqueado sólo unos
cuantos transeúntes lo cruzan en
dirección a su cráneo la frontera con
bielorrusia está a menos de dos
kilómetros y atrás se ven las posiciones
ucranianas esta cercanía creó un gran
temor en la población después del 24 de
febrero también que las tropas rusas
fueran entrar por este lugar se han ido
adaptando pero la retórica que ha salido
de bielorrusia en las últimas semanas ha
vuelto incrementar el temor poblaciones
como doma nube han quedado marcadas por
el miedo desde el primer día de la
guerra entonces el gobierno del
presidente bielorruso alexander
lukachenko aliado de moscú permitió que
las tropas rusas avanzaron hacia la
región de kiev desde su territorio en
esta zona noroccidental del país
pensaron que podía suceder lo mismo
os da cuenta que tenía tanto miedo que
el terror se apoderaba de todo su cuerpo
no sabíamos a dónde ir que llevar con
nosotros no sabíamos que había ni qué
pasaba gente nosotros seríamos capaces
de escondernos en algún lugar
junto con su familia buscó refugio en un
lugar seguro de ucrania pero regresaron
una semana después no podían dejar el
campo abandonado tenían que cuidar de
los cultivos que ahora recogen le
preocupa a su hija de tres años que
constantemente pregunta si van a venir
lo que ella llama los hombres malos
ahora hay tensión pero es un poco
diferente no tan miedoso hemos visto
como los militares aprendieron a pelear
los vimos repeler a los rusos en el s al
miedo de una invasión se suma la
preocupación por la economía las
cosechas no han sido buenas y nadie las
compra
mariah regenta la única tienda del
pueblo teme al futuro especialmente a la
ausencia de gas en invierno dice que si
la situación continúa la gente podría
morir de hambre
la gente se fue de aquí sin dinero no
queda ningún lugar donde puedan hacer
dinero algunos se fueron a polonia
especialmente familias con niños o
solteros
en esta zona fronteriza esperan que el
ataque temido nunca llegue aunque por el
momento han tenido que aprender a vivir
con su fantasma